so one of my heroes Warren Buffett he
finished top of his class at Columbia
somebody who finished his top of their
class at Columbia can get a job paying
very well in most places but guess what
he did he asked Ben Graham to let him
work at his investment firm for free
because he realized that he was going to
get more than he could possibly be
compensated for and guess what Ben
Graham said to him when he asked him to
work for him he said you're overpriced
because Ben Graham knew just as Warren
Buffett knew that even though he was
working for free it was going to cost
Ben Graham more to deliver all of the
skills and all of the things that he
would need to be successful than the
monetary compensation but because Warren
Buffett is smart he realized that he was
in a season of learning and not earning
yet and so he was willing to invest as
one of the greatest investors of all
time in the thing that was most
important and valuable to him at the
time himself